j'ai commencé par celui qui s'intitule
La Honte Annie Arnaud et là on va voir
d'ailleurs comment ça se passe chez vous
la première phrase c'est tout simplement
mon père a voulu tuer et ma mère un
dimanche de juin au début de
l'après-midi point c'est-à-dire tout de
suite hop on dit la chose la plus
lapidaire
et c'est une c'est votre manière je
dirais ça c'est à dire que cette
première phrase qui ouvre qui ouvre la
honte c'est la phrase avec laquelle je
me suis toujours
dit à l'intérieur de moi-même cette
scène depuis qu'elle a eu lieu un
dimanche dans dans l'été de le mois de
juin de mes 12 ans et j'ai toujours j'ai
essayé de dans ce livre justement de
rester au niveau au niveau de la chose
ressentie à cette époque là et non pas
maintenant et non pas maintenant donc de
retrouver d'une certaine passons presque
les les mots intégralement les mots de
cette époque là mais les mots qui
pouvaient rendre le plus la sensation ce
qui est vrai donc vous voyez cette scène
bon votre père ne tue pas votre mère
mais tout de suite vous en ressentez une
honte parce que vous avez vu ce que vous
n'auriez pas dû voir vous aussi il y a
il y a cela bien sûr il y a eu d'abord
la peur que la chose que le drame se
reproduise et cette fois Aya son terme
mais très vite il y a eu la honte cette
honte elle venait je pense de ce que
d'un seul coup par ce geste qui était
tout à fait surprenant de la part de mon
père qui était un homme très doux et que
ce geste nous plaçait en fait
dans le même monde que celui où mes
parents avaient leur petit commerce
d'épicerie café un monde qui était comme
on dirait maintenant avec féminisme
défavorisé pour la plupart il y avait
beaucoup d'alcoolisme il y avait des
scènes commence également mais mes
parents a fait avaient un mode de vie
qui était peut-être un peu différent
dans la hiérarchie sociale un peu au
dessus et brusquement nous étions dans
ce monde-là et il ne faut pas oublier
que moi j'allais à l'école privée
catholique ce qui était un peu mon Henri
IV à moi et
donc d'un seul coup j'ai je suis devenue
indigne de ce monde de l'école privée et
dans le monde populaire où je vivais
cette scène même était également
aurait été sujet de de Rago aurait été
sujet du honte
n'est pas dans les journaux elle n'est
pas elle serait ça ne fait rien je veux
dire que le poids de la honte le poids
de la douleur n'est pas mesurable avec
le fait que qu'on soit que ce soit
connue c'est c'était je crois que à
partir de cette scène je crois qu'avec
cette scène qui a coupé mon enfance en
deux j'ai pris conscience de mon
appartenance sociale par la honte et
c'est bien sûr ce n'était pas une pensée
et construite
ces termes même d'appartenance
naturellement ne pouvait pas me venir et
la seule phrase qui m'était venue c'est
j'ai gagné malheur
ce que vous dites tu vas me faire gagner
malheur c'est une phrase étonnante
qu'on emploie en Normandie peut-être
encore qui signifiait en fait devenir
fou à partir de d'un choc une chose en
fait une chose effrayante et c'était ne
plus être comme avant
cet événement non primordial c'est la
honte sociale d'appartenir à une d'être
jugée toujours par les gens plus riches
et c'est ça qui est fort parce que cet
événement initial c'est un sujet de
stuvski presque enfin une espèce de
Luxor ici de tentative du et après c'est
une la honte ordinaire qui il me semble
pire encore
déclenché tout un processus je dis je
suis entré dans la honte et qu'ensuite
tout va devenir d'une certaine manière
sentiment de honte mais c'est que
quelque chose c'est d'essayer en moi
j'ai vu ce que je ne vais pas voir je
dis mais c'est surtout ce sentiment donc
de
m'en donne plus d'être en fait dans un
autre monde que le beau monde de l'école
privée cette excellence que l'on réclame
de nous et c'est excellent si vous étiez
vous-même excellente vous le dites il y
a une phrase très belle olive dit le
pire dans la honte c'est qu'on croit
être seul à l'éprouver ça c'est ça la
honte en fait il y a des millions de
gens qui étaient dans une situation mais
vous ne saviez pas et c'est ça la honte
être honteux c'est être seul alors
c'était le c'était Annie Arnaud c'était
le dimanche 15 juin 1952 comme ça s'est
passé et là vous allez chercher à
remplacer ce
dans le contexte de l'actualité alors
vous allez consulter la collection de
Paris Normandie et puis dans le contexte
de votre famille dans le contexte social
de l'époque et ce qui nous vaut ce livre
qui est une sorte de technologie je le
disais tout à l'heure de du moment du
lieu et des et de ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là de ce que vous ressentez de
comment sont les hommes et comment sont
les femmes et ainsi de suite parce que
je crois que je dis un moment il n'y a
pas de vrai mémoire de soi et je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse reconstituer son
enfance à partir de ces seuls souvenirs
de ses seules images et je par exemple
je pense que la petite fille de 12 ans
dont j'ai gardé les photos de photos et
qui est moi elle m'est plus étrangère
que n'importe quelle petite fille de 12
ans que je croise dans la rue ou qui est
assise à côté de moi dans le train il y
a je vis avec cet enfant dans le même
monde avec la petite fille de 1952 il y
a tellement peu de choses de communes il
y a le monde a changé et ce ne sont plus
les mêmes règles sociales les règles le
moral et donc j'ai essayé essayer de
reconstruire le monde de cette époque et
les règles et les codes auxquelles votre
famille obéissait l'école et sans savoir
parce que vous n'avez que 12 ans qu'il y
a d'autres codes bien entendu
dans ce la et c'est ça qui est qui est
fascinant
dans ce livre
oui le
et puis là je me disais toujours parce
que je crois que j'ai avoir lu tous vos
livres et je lui disais c'est
j'arrivais pas à trouver la fin
il y a ce livre qui s'appelle une
passion simple dans lequel vous
racontiez avec une vérité très forte la
passion vous avez eu pour un homme et
sans rien et je ne sais vidéo dans le
monde qui disait que dès les premières
pages vous employés les mots que les
mots sperme parce que c'est la vérité
parce que vous voulez dire cette vérité
et que vous n'employez pas de de
métaphore ni de féminisme vous avez soit
je me disais comment elle raconte ça
comment comment dire quel est le danger
de ces livres et puis hop évidemment
parce que le décrivant que moi je ne le
suis pas et ben il y a la réponse qui
est page 132 j'ai toujours eu envie
offrir des livres dont il me soit
ensuite impossible de parler qui rendent
le regard d'autrui insoutenables ça
c'est admirable
ce livre qui m'a expliqué tout ce que
j'avais fait oui
d'ailleurs pour l'autre aussi alors je
disais oui le style ça c'est Jacques
pirate dans le point qui a fait un très
bon très bon article sur vos deux
ouvrages il dit de alors on va parler
d'ailleurs de l'autre là mais enfin ça
vaut pour celui-ci aussi
c'est donc
je vais lire après voilà sincérité et
simplicité totale mais aussi quel œil
qu'elle acide quel sécheresse va donc
voilà tous ces mots c'est pour ça et au
fond est-ce que vous aimez alors vous
qui employez donc des grandes phrases
avec beaucoup d'incidents est-ce que
vous aimez ce style très si oui et oui
j'aime le style de chaque
oui c'était j'aime le lire mais je ne
pourrais pas écrire
et agnire nous dit à un moment je crois
que vous le dites noirceau blanc que
voulez-vous garder de l'émotion or elle
passe terriblement et peut-être d'autant
plus que ces phrases sont brèves et
sèches et j'aime énormément standard qui
n'est pas un auteur à longfrage alors on
va mener de concert les deux livres sur
la médias Alzheimer celui d'ami Arnaud
alors quand votre mère dont vous avez
raconté vous avez des peintres dans une
femme
a été atteint de la maladie d'Alzheimer
alors là vous avez pris des notes je
pense que la seule moment de votre vie
peut-être pourquoi je prends des notes
souvent mais pas des notes comme
celle-là je veux dire que celle m'est
venue ma mère était chez moi elle
commençait d'avoir les premiers signes
de la maladie d'Alzheimer d'agence même
pas que c'était la maladie d'Alzheimer
et à chaque fois qu'il avait une
conduite qui était aberrante et qu'elle
je notais je notais je ne peux pas
expliquer pourquoi et lorsqu'elle a été
ensuite dans la maison de retraite de
l'hôpital
de Pontoise j'allais la voir et après
chaque visite c'était comme c'était
comme un besoin une urgence d'écrire
d'écrire ce que je venais de voir ça
comment il était ce jour-là ce qui
s'était passé entre les mois et voilà ça
formait peu à peu donc un journal mais
jusqu'à sa mort mais je ne pensais pas
du tout le public qui est oui là aussi
parce que c'est difficile et puis tout
ce vous dit de ce livre c'est un résidu
de douleur je crois que c'est peut être
vu comme ça enfin pour moi c'est ça
vous avez beaucoup souffert mais cette
mère vous l'avez détesté vous l'avez
détesté vous-même parce qu'elle vous
haïssait parce que parce que elle avait
une fille dont vous a une fille aînée
qui est morte et dont vous avez pris la
place parce qu'elle n'avait qu'un code
vous parlez des codes avec un code
c'était la religion et qu'elle vous a
servi à ce code et que mais oui mais
c'est il y a eu l'amour au départ ma
mère j'ai écrit j'ai toujours j'ai dû
chercher partout dans le monde sur le
c'est son amour partout dans le monde et
je crois que c'était la personne la plus
importante pour moi telle qu'elle était
avec ses codes que j'ai ensuite
violemment refusé à l'adolescence et
tout ressurgit au moment de sa maladie
d'Alzheimer parce qu'elle est elle a des
accès de de parole violentes ou elles
resurgit ce chemin tout ce que j'ai
testé
alors le titre je ne suis pas sorti de
Manu entre guillemets c'est je connais
la réponse
les derniers mots que ma mère a écrit
dans une lettre à une amie et elle n'a
pas pu terminer sa lettre parce que une
des caractéristiques de cette maladie
c'est qu'on ne peut plus écrire à partir
d'un moment et cette phrase mais
revenait continuellement chaque fois que
j'allais la voir parce que elle ne
pouvait plus écrire du tout et même ces
mots là elle n'aurait pas pu les écrire
et je crois aussi que ce titre là c'est
je pense que ma mère qui aimait
tellement lire qui aimait qui admirait
tellement la littérature
bien qu'elle n'ait jamais fait d'études
et bien je crois que c'est un peu à
cause d'elle que j'ai écrit
[Musique]